[Musique]
83 hommes
tous morts en moins de cinq minutes
[Musique]
c'est une chose effrayante tenais ce que
la mort peut atteindre
[Musique]
les hommes y sont morts
la mine les après pour les hommes
comment cette charmante ville de la
belle s'en est sorti pour un homme et il
faut bien quelqu'un fasse tourner la
ville est une ville où il n'y a que deux
femmes
[Musique]
frémur pour les bandits
franck griffin est à la recherche de rue
gould il tuera tous pour qui rend et
good attriste
ces braves gens de crime dans les ce et
reporter leurs oeufs aujourd'hui plus de
relais du personnel
et quand ils découvrir à quel genre
d'habitants vit annabelle que dieu vous
vient d'en être
monsieur on est beaucoup plus forte que
vous le pensez
j'ai quelque chose à faire
[Musique]
j'ai à dire le malheur ça ne fait au
moins un point commun la terre du
poignard et du fusil c'est la terre
c'est chaud
restons tous calme et discutons comme
des personnes civilisées un prix entre
et suggère que d'abord nous baissions
mozart